um and and it's like what the [ __ ] like
what do you do when it starts to
manifest in these negative things when
they as an adult I don't want to be
insensitive but me and my friends
molested each other I mean like it's
different when you touch each other with
the food you guys do we after I remember
one time after we were Anna pull me and
my friend we were told to change and
then he he stuck out his dick and he
started walking over and then I grabbed
my dick and I started walking to him and
we said saw pie and then we started
making seem like we made those noises
it's like that's so funny beside them I
don't know if we call that mother
station but that's for sure like kids
are like this is a dick you got a dick
let's play dicks but then that the the
tip rubbing felt good though so we just
kept going
that's your first gay experience and you
don't even [ __ ] know dude that's
pretty gay yeah but like we were like
Bobby Lee and his sakes or something
it's like Bobby Lee and [ __ ] sucking
dick with the sucking his best friend's
dick not that his friend was gay though
and so he's asked him for it I feel like
he was tricked into sucking his dick
yeah cuz I don't think it happened the
other way around I think he just got his
dick sucked oh and he was tricked oh my
god it's just so funny it's like oh well
how old were you when you got a
swordfight like six or something damn I
can't remember doing anything with my
dick that made me feel good at that age
really mm-hmm I would [ __ ] do all
kinds of [ __ ] my neighbor she she was
she's so crazy she had this thing where
she always had to see somebody's dick
what we would all show her our dick
close she she was around okay you say
major like eight or nine though at that
time we were older she just wanted to
see like everyone's dick and then she
had this little kind of like Playhouse
thing and then she would ask us if she
could see it and then we would pull it
out what the [ __ ] but like she wouldn't
touch it or anything she just wanted to
see my childhood curiosity it's like
it's different it's not mine
I guess so that's so weird I wonder at
what age worse like that's a little odd
because I feel like if little kids did
that [ __ ] it's just kind of like oh you
don't have what I have but we were
turned on but I didn't know what I was
being turned on like I was just like you
guys got up sexually a lot faster than I
did though cuz I don't I feel like when
I was maybe I I don't know what age it
was though exactly so it's hard to say
but I don't remember being like turned
on per se like I can't remember that
[ __ ] I just remembered to survive like
just [ __ ] just play out in the Sun
all day that's [ __ ] crazy yeah it's
pretty nuts maybe that's why you're
insane dude you molested me I don't know
well there was an older girl too
that took piano lessons from my dad and
oh this is a crazy story because her mom
and my dad had an affair no [ __ ] but I
had an affair with her too what was an
affair but so like her mom and her would
play would take singing lessons and
piano lessons from my dad so you bring
me over to go come play with her and
then um so she she pulled me in the
closet and then asked me if I want to
touch her boobs and I was like sure and
I was under ten or something I was
really young how old is she she was a
couple years older than me so she had
boobs already oh she said so she let me
play with their boobs so I don't know I
guess I got molested I don't know but
then I liked it and I think this is
right or wrong but I didn't I don't know
man like she it was exploring and [ __ ]
and then like she's young too though is
it I think 12 and 10 mentally it's
pretty similar right yeah but but it was
like super steamy and [ __ ] and like
her mom was like oh where are you and
then like I was like oh we're hiding in
the closet and then we're giggling and
then we came out and then like I was
like [ __ ] I don't know if they they
caught us or whatever but it was another
time where I learned that from that girl
and I was playing with another girl that
was having a piano lesson at our house
and I had a fort and we were playing
fort and then so I asked her if I can
rub her boobies she didn't even have
boobie she just had nipples cuz we were
so young yeah yeah and then like I would
she would let me but then somehow we are
clothes started coming
and then it was like my dad was like
where are you guys and then we're like
we're hiding and then we're like trying
to put our clothes on and then like we
got in such [ __ ] deep [ __ ] cuz my dad
opened up the blanket [ __ ] and we're
like two [ __ ] kids like pretty much
half [ __ ] naked not knowing what
we're doing I didn't know about sex back
then you know that's so weird because I
feel like as a parent is shocking but I
feel like getting like kind of
chastising your kid for that and said
everybody done like hey let me take you
aside like yeah we're like [ __ ] I don't
know like anywhere from like six to
that's how lined that's a it's like
prepubescent age yeah and I didn't know
anything about sex dude I just knew that
it like felt good to like hug them and
whatever and so and the girls too were
like that's at the same age but I'm like
was it mutual
pretty much damn I don't remember